do you think Consciousness is
fundamentally uh computational
so when you think about CX what can we
turn into computation
and you're thinking about llms
do you think
the uh the display of Consciousness and
the experience of cautiousness the hard
problem is is fundamentally uh
that computation yeah what it feels like
inside so to speak is
you know I I did a little exercise
eventually I'll I'll post it of uh you
know what it's like to be a computer
yeah right it's kind of like well you
get all this sensory input you have a
kind of the way I see it is from the
time you boot a computer to the time the
computer crashes is like a human life
you you're building up a certain amount
of State in memory you remember certain
things about your quote's life
eventually it's kind of like the the uh
you know the next generation of humans
is is born from the same genetic
material so to speak with a little bit
left over left on the disc so to speak
um and then you know the the new fresh
generation starts up and eventually all
kinds of crud builds up in the in the
memory of the computer and eventually
the thing crashes or whatever or maybe
it has some trauma because you plugged
in some weird thing to some Port of the
computer and that made it crash and that
um uh you know that that's kind of but
but you have this this picture of you
know from from startup to to to shut
down you know what is the life of a
computer so to speak and what does it
feel like to be that computer and what
inner thoughts does it have and how do
you describe it and it's kind of kind of
interesting as you start writing about
this to realize it's awfully like what
you'd say about yourself that is it's
awfully like even an ordinary computer
forget all the AI stuff and so on you
know it's kind of it has a memory of the
past it has certain sensory experiences
it can communicate with other computers
but it has to package up how it's
communicating in some kind of language
like form so it can you know send so it
can kind of map what's in its memory to
what's in the memory of some other
computer it's it's a surprisingly
similar thing you know I hadn't
experience just a week or two ago I I
had I'm a collector of all possible data
about myself and other things and so I
you know I collect all sorts of weird
medical data and so on and one thing I
hadn't collected was I'd never had a
whole body MRI scan so I went and got
one of these yes okay so I get that get
all the data back right I'm looking at
this thing I never looked at the kind of
insides of my brain so to speak
um in in physical form and it's really I
mean it's kind of psychologically
shocking in a sense that you know here's
this thing and you can see it has all
these folds and all these you know the
structure and it's like that's where
this experience that I'm having of you
know existing and so on yeah that's
where it is and you know it feels very
you know you look at that and you're
thinking how can this possibly be all
this experience that I'm having and
you're realizing well I can look at a
computer as well and it's it's kind of
this it it I think this idea that you
are having an experience that is somehow
um
you know transcends the mere sort of
physicality of that experience I I I I
you know it's something that's hard to
come to terms with but I think you know
and I I don't think I'm necessarily you
know my my personal experience you know
I look at the you know the MRI of the
brain and then I you know know about all
kinds of things about neuroscience and
all that kind of stuff and I still feel
the way I feel so to speak and it it
sort of seems disconnected but yet as I
try and rationalize it I can't really
say that there's something kind of
different about how I intrinsically feel
from the thing that I can plainly see in
the sort of physicality of what's going
on so do you think the computer a large
language model will experience that
Transcendence
how does it make you feel like I I tend
to believe it will I think an ordinary
computer is already there I think an
ordinary computer is already you know
kind of it's it's now a large language
model may experience it in a way that is
much better aligned with us humans that
is it's much more you know if you could
have the discussion with the computer
it's intelligent so to speak is not
particularly well aligned with ours but
the large language model is you know
it's built to be aligned with our way of
thinking about things you'll be able to
explain that it's uh afraid of being
shut off and deleted it'd be able to say
that it's sad of the way you've been
speaking to it over the past two days
but you know that's a weird thing
because when it says it's afraid of
something but we know that it got that
idea from the fact that it read on the
internet yeah what did you get it Steven
where did you get it when you say you're
afraid you're quite that's the question
yeah right I mean it's it's parents your
friends right or or my biology I mean in
other words there's a certain amount
that is you know the endocrine system
kicking in and and you know the the um
uh these kinds of emotional overlay type
things that happen to be that are
actually much more physical even they're
much more sort of straightforwardly
chemical than the the then kind of all
of the higher level thinking yeah but
your biology didn't tell you to say I'm
afraid just at the right time when
people that love you are listening and
so you know you're manipulating them by
saying so that's not your biology that's
no that's a well but the you know it's a
large language model and that biological
neural network of yours yes but I mean
the intrinsic thing of you know
something sort of shocking is just
happening and you have some sort of
reaction which is you know some
neurotransmitter gets secreted and it's
um uh you know that that is the
beginning of some you know that is
that's one of the pieces of input that
then draw lives it's kind of like the uh
like a prompt for for the large language
model I mean just like when we dream for
example you know no doubt there are all
these sort of random inputs they're kind
of these random prompts and that's
percolating through in kind of the way
that a large language model does of kind
of putting together things that seem
meaningful
I I mean are you uh are you worried
about this world where you you teach a
lot on the internet and there's people
asking questions and comments and so on
uh you have people that work remotely
um are you worried about this world when
um large language models
create human-like Bots
that are
leaving the comments asking the
questions I might even become fake
employees yeah
I mean or or or uh worse or better at
yet friends friends of yours right look
I mean one point is my mode of life has
been I build tools and then I use the
tools yeah and in a sense kind of you
know I'm I'm building this Tower of
automation yes which you know and in a
sense you know when you make a company
or something you are making sort of
automation but it has some humans in it
but also as much as possible it has it
has uh you know computers in it and so I
think it's sort of an extension of that
now now if I really didn't know that um
you know it's a it's a it's a funny
question it's a it's a funny issue when
you know if we think about sort of
what's going to happen to the future of
kind of jobs people do and so on and
there are places where kind of having a
human in the loop there are different
reasons to have a human in a loop for
example you might want a human in the
loop because you want somebody to you
want another human to be invested in the
outcome you know you want a human flying
the plane who's going to die if the
plane crashes along with you so to speak
and that gives you sort of confidence
that the right thing is going to happen
or you might want you know right now you
might want a human in the loop in some
kind of sort of human encouragement
persuasion type profession whether that
will continue I'm not sure for those
types of professions because it may be
that the the greater efficiency of uh
you know of being able to have sort of
just the right information delivered at
just the right time will overcome the
kind of the the kind of oh yes I want a
human there yeah imagine like a
therapist or even higher stake like a
suicide hotline operated by a large
language model yeah who boy it's a
pretty high stake situation right but I
mean but you know it might in fact do
the right thing yeah because it might be
the case that that um you know and
that's really partly a question of sort
of how complicated is the human you know
one of the things that's that's always
surprising in some sense is that you
know sometimes human psychology is not
that complicated in some sense
you wrote the blog post